Comcast also 100 years of Universal
movies now owned by your local cable
company once upon a time snow white
story narrated by thorn hey that girl
looks like Disney's Snow White I'm sure
that's just a coincidence though if only
I had a child is white as snow that's
racist generic fantasy setting an extras
also discount Disney Castle Iook after
its child Snow White has a British
accent
grown-up Snow White later in the movie
does not which may or may not have
something to do with the casting thank
you William the director said let's have
your character take one bite of an apple
then throw it on the ground it'll make
you look like even more of an asshole
there's no Crites mother passed away
from what happiness
the Ottomans defeated Foley prologue
what is this a Peter Jackson movie this
knife wound is slowly oozing purple
kool-aid and certainly not gushing blood
as it should be
also Charlize Theron scare achter turns
out to be evil and my penis doesn't
carry cliche and a little sister I love
calling each other by our familial
relationship she had tricked her way
into the kingdom if he's still talking
yeah this is not a mirror it's more of a
Gong I don't I use creative license to
change mirrors into completely different
things but this movie did it's you my
queen great answer did you have to spill
out onto the floor and turn into a
hooded figure to tell her this Oh
bluch Valley Evil Queen keeps princess
alive just because so poisonous who's
the reigning of Ravenna look if you're
fourteen minutes into your movie and you
still need a narrator setting it up
you've done up already
Snow White says the Lord's Prayer while
clutching some homemade voodoo dolls is
the Duke's son still alive I don't know
says you would definitely know that
don't be dumb you'll be teases us with
pg-13 milk bath nudity I have something
what ails you
haha gross now naira
this bastard is already out before she
even says the words on this day one has
come of age there even than you we had
to wait until she was 18 because it was
creepy to say she was hot just yesterday
she's the reason your powers wane even
magic-mirror rates play the pronoun game
how is it snow white movie asks us to
compare the beauty of Kristen Stewart to
Charlize freakin Theron come on magic
mirror is magic don't make us choose
whether it's a magic mirror or a crazy
Queen she was a child well hindsight is
20/20 I guess but in this case foresight
should have been 20/20 her innocence and
purity is all that can destroy you huh
movie makes virtuous innocent reference
about female star caught cheating with
the director take her heart in your hand
and you shall never again need to
consume you you could have told me this
a few years ago magic mirror what an
asshole
a bird saving the day this is a Peter
Jackson movie course Finn is the creepy
type who lusts after Snow White this
comes out of nowhere by the way one
simple shot of Finn watching Snow
White's leap would have fixed the
problem but the movie Springs it on us
here also this is extremely fortunate
for Snow White giving her a chance to
make an escape wait he got out I mean I
guess he screamed until a guard came to
let him out and that might be enough if
we had ever seen a single guard posted
down in that dungeon jeez will with all
the helpful birds all of Snow White's
life will help you when you turn 18 and
have been in prison for a long time just
go to the ocean
she went down in the sewers nowhere else
for her to go
shortly before banging Kristen Stewart
the director obviously watched the
fugitive bring her back to me
unnecessary orders mother gain birds I
mean why not just have pages of the
script float by for her to look at or
give her Google Maps or something it's
not like you actually care about
creating a justifiable reason for her to
do things it's worse
convenient escape horse or the fact that
it too is all-white wait didn't they
know snow white jumped into the sewers
and probably landed in the ocean did
they know she'd have a horse waiting for
were down at the beach why didn't they
check there first how do they know she
went in this direction damn those
blasted mud puddles the magical horses
only weakness
now Snow White has to carry on by
herself oh is it an innocent young girl
makes a fool of my brother how is it
that a good actress has turned into a
bad one so quickly she'd had a sword
she'd had taken my kingdom how do you
figure
have I not given you yes sister uh-huh
gross she can't bring your wife back
from the dead you Oh
why would you say this even if you think
you can overpower the Huntsman and
recapture Snow White what benefit do you
have by telling the truth now we
interrupt the snow white movie to bring
you one of the creepy forests from a
Peter Jackson Middle Earth movie I don't
care which one take your pick
Forrest indistinct for your weakness
actually it gained strength from
whatever the screenwriter says it does
nothing has happened for a long time so
it was time to break out the branches
turn into snakes bit also this forest is
parallax how terrible a forest can this
thing be if this many people know it
well earlier you made it sound like the
Huntsman was the only one who'd survived
its evil but now every cell sword in the
hill country knows that does it not
probably survive Billa Swann is
suggesting to Thor what I think she is
about Aeon Flux that beats my fanfiction
how to turn a child's fairy tale into a
fantasy action-adventure just add random
monsters
if Snow White's mystical purity and
innocence is some magical thing why did
it take so long for the troll to figure
this out did he need to look her in the
eyes first furthermore what is the troll
doing right now I recognize your snow
white now I'm gonna sit here and stare
at you awhile so you can let that sink
in I told you to run I had you'd be dead
or is oblivious to the entire situation
so that he can act like a Neanderthal
and Snow White can have a cheap moment
of empowerment this movie is basically
two people walking and talking and every
now and then some small stuff happens
it's like the Book of Eli only with fear
actors and fear action and it's not like
the Book of Eli was some masterpiece or
anything so think on that for a minute
mom only is not a suitable medical
moment didn't trust you I know we need
some conflict here romantically but he's
mad that she didn't trust him he
literally said I don't trust you when he
met her and agreed to help her house
cause protectors that beauty we are
worthless to the Queen gee thanks for
answering that awkward question I didn't
ask also how do the scars make you
worthless to the Queen earlier we saw
her suck youth directly out of a girl
not sure the beauty had anything to do
with it but even if it did can't she
make you a slave or a kitchen worker or
some more unnecessary orders and this
movie has a lot of pseudo nudity or
nudity both nonsensical dream snippet
villain backstory I be warned by fairest
blood this spell can be undone if this
spell was supposed to retain her beauty
and the only thing that can mess it up
is Snow White why did she need to keep
taking all those other women's souls
also what about Finn how did you survive
this poorly constructed flashback she's
worth a lot of gold to me which I'm
happy to share with you Superboy why
would you say this does she speak the
truth yes she is of the blood damn
everyone and everything in this movie
can tell she's Snow White from five feet
away even though no one in the kingdom
has seen or smelled her in a dozen years
or more we interrupt the snow white
movie to bring you Tim Burton's Snow
White I think I'm actually starting to
get mad here Molly not on the movie you
started out in that's for sure this is
obviously the part of the filming where
the director had just become infatuated
with Kristen Stewart and started adding
nonsense to the script to give her more
screen time I'll add a you Wi-Fi tragic
waste of Nick Frost yeah what scrape and
say
works in the picture singing is required
oh that explains it also what the fuck
also man there's fairy tales and then
there's shooting a movie after you eat
shrooms also we interrupt the snow white
movie to bring you the adult version of
the grid Neck aliens from Galaxy Quest
hey it's Harry Potter's dad this movie
was cooler when the Evil Queen had some
magic and everything else was kind of
normal ish now it's literally anything
can happen in this movie which makes it
pointless she is the one discount white
dwarf Morpheus random mercenaries are
able to sneak up on magical creatures no
problem previously weakling pervy
brother of the Queen turns out to be a
badass fighter so that the scene can
happen now you can fake
giving us any other world what makes
villains so talkative during
premeditated murder also what makes him
so talkative around prefabricated death
traps this wound books destroyed and
replaced his penis but we're supposed to
care about this guy's death because he
danced with Snow White a few minutes ago
that was practically his only character
treat more required dwarf singing hush
the whales at the oh I'm all out of
fucks to give for that dwarf that danced
with Snow White that one time we
interrupt the snow white movie to bring
you the best cinematography from
Fellowship of the Ring geez I've sang
about this guy's death longer than he
was actually living in the fall movie
she hasn't changed she has that same
light inside her characters constantly
tell us how special Snow White is even
though the only character trait we've
seen is that she's really nice this is
exactly like Band of Brothers only
without the quality camerawork brilliant
acting powerful story and my interest
level after obviously poisoning Snow
White Apple is obligated after one bite
to punch us in the nose that it's bad
for you this is a cool reveal and all
but how the fuck did she know we're snow
white walls and don't say magic because
when she escaped earlier Raveena
memorably said
so lucky you are never to know it is to
grow Oh wonder if we'll ever be lucky
enough to see a villain who doesn't talk
the protagonists Kiera before killing
them she doesn't need to fly away does
she we've seen her get stabbed she can't
die the only thing that can kill her is
Snow White so couldn't she just kill
these guys no problem then take Snow
White's heart why does she need to
escape
dwarf use whoa whoa whoa nobody said
anything about healers until now and
besides if they had the power to heal
don't you think they would have saved
their buddy they mourn for five minutes
at this movie Ravena is a dick to
herself
ear braids until you just can kiss her
already so we can get on with it Jesus
see you remind me of a protagonist
reminds guy of his dead wife cliche this
is a true love's kiss that the movie did
not earn never once do these two
characters appear to be falling in love
this is true love because the filmmakers
say it is also I know this is a typical
variation in the Snow White story to
have a kiss wake her up but what kind of
stupid poison spell is created with this
kind of weakness is it the rule of all
spells to be broken by something
completely out of left field
typical rally the troops speech in case
you need that from every movie since
Braveheart so once she's an instant
battle expert now she was a little girl
received no training spent several years
in prison and then we had one moment
where the Huntsman showed her one move
but sure put her in armor and let her
lead the attack the fuck out of here
Elijah something up hey stop twisting no
special Tyson haha
that classic Disney Snow White that
everyone loves it's a pussy compared to
this battle heavy snow white oh hello is
it wolf right son well since dwarves
also weed through poo in the hobbit the
desolation of smaug you may have set the
bar as low as it can get there very
fetching in man or very fetching on male
am i right we interrupt the snow white
movie to bring you spider-man 3 why does
anyone think it's a good idea for Snow
White to face off with the magical Queen
by herself again she has no combat
training al she threw her shield down as
soon as she saw the Queen what does that
tell you also movie that sets out to
turn Snow White from dainty princess
into Joan of Arc action hero does
nothing the entire movie to establish
Snow White's ability to fight or do
anything different from the original
Snow White except put on armor Queen who
can suck Souls waste time monologuing
instead of just killing the only person
who can stop her reign the only move she
learned is the only move she needed and
totally by fairest blood is it undone
seems kind of a douchey thing for the
fairest of them all to say
yeah I don't think the rule of three
applies here there would be a lot more
blood than that movie deals with its own
half-assed love triangle by not really
dealing with it at all
look what I'm afraid of
we put so many chocolate cookies into
Hershey's cookies and cream you get a
mouth full of cookies and every bite of
our delicious white chocolate
Percy's cookies and cream boo a mouth
full of cookies in every bite
the cliffs of insanity
your soul is mine this forest is old
please you're letting a service this
ones get to you remember only you can
prevent forest fires
you wanted me to be human
watch me
for these you will stay with me any
other way
please
and crawl to freedom through 500 yards
of smelling foul as I can't even imagine
already I just don't want to
so the naturebox shipments have
continued and I have greatly enjoyed the
delicious snack foods they send but the
most recent shipment came while I was
out watching Godzilla and I was not at
home to receive the nature box so I come
home to find the box inside the house on
the kitchen table wide and open Cats
halfway through a bag of plantain chips
now you might think I'd be mad at the
cats but you'd be wrong I just cats man
they don't know any better a real
asshole in this situation is the
delivery guy I mean who looks at a cat
answering the door and says yeah this
looks like a reliable caretaker for
delicious human snacks that's not even
getting into the question of how the
cats open the door or learn to forge my
signature but I've got more media
problems right now not as snacks
naturebox delicious healthy snacks
delivered right to your door with free
shipping go to nature box Commons for a
special 50% off order just for our
viewers just make sure you leave
detailed instructions for the delivery
guy on the trustworthiness of your cats